this video proposed to show fighters
from preparing military rapid support
forces at the presidential Palace in
hartum it houses the office of the de
facto head of state who's also the head
of the army General Abdel fattah
al-burhan but the rsf says it's in
control of this government building
there's been more intense fighting in
the capital as the two sides battle for
control that's despite the announcement
of an extension of a ceasefire for one
week after mediation efforts by South
Sudan's president salvagir
that's the sound of artillery being
fired by the rapid support forces
against Sudanese Army fighter jets that
have been flying overhead around the
vicinity of the presidential Palace
since the early hours of Wednesday
morning now Fierce battles have been
ongoing between the rsf and the Sudanese
Army as the Army looks like it's pushing
to regain control of the presidential
Palace which has been under the control
of the rapid support forces since the
start of the fighting 19 days ago the UN
says the deteriorating situation is
making it difficult to deliver Aid its
humanitarian Chief who visited Port
Sudan says security guarantees are
needed even when there is no formal
magical ceasefire we will still require
agreements and arrangements to allow for
movement of staff and supplies we will
need to have agreements at the highest
level
and very publicly and we will need to
deliver those commitments into local
Arrangements that can be depended on the
fighting and instability is pushing more
families to flee the capital this bus of
evacuees is heading north to the Eastern
Red Sea Coast along the way they pass
through several checkpoints some are
controlled by the Army others by the
paramilitary rapid support forces
people coming from Khartoum who are
escaping the war and trying to find
Safety and Security arrive here under
very difficult circumstances some people
who have passed through here don't have
food some are sick some are very old in
Port Sudan Navy ships commercial ferries
and airplanes are shuttling people out
of the country authorities say around 13
000 foreign Nationals have left in
recent weeks but more evacuees arrive
each day and the city is struggling to
go
we've had a big problem with
accommodation in the area syrians are
currently living on the street some
families open their houses to families
but for us youths we've been staying in
the mosques and we've been getting help
with basic needs food and drink
despite the poor conditions the influx
into Port Sudan will likely go on until
the whirring sites agreed to a ceasefire
that holds Heber Morgan Al Jazeera
cartoon